Another kind of
group that does seem
happiest is people who
report being satisfied
with their relationships.
So that's both romantic
relationships but, also,
in terms of people who have
lots of friends, who spend lots
of time with their
friends, this is
one of the biggest predictors
of who is happy and who's not.
It's basically your
personal relationships.
So you see here that people
who say that they're satisfied
with their relationships report
being much happier than people
who report not being satisfied.
Now, another one is money.
And money gets people really
interested about happiness.
Because in many
ways, we don't really
like to think that money
leads to happiness.
You know, we have
this idea that, oh,
you can't buy happiness.
Happiness comes from within.
I still don't really understand
where the idea came from.
Because, to me, if you
look across countries,
rich countries are happier
than poor countries--
quite straightforward.
Within countries, if you're
poor within a country,
then you're less happy that if
you're rich within a country.
So at least
cross-sectionally, that's
if you measure
one point of time,
money does lead to happiness,
especially at the low end.
So especially for
those people who
earn little amounts of money,
even very small increases
can dramatically improve
people's well-being.
But it's not just
about having money.
There is also
increasing evidence
about how you use your money
impacts your happiness.
So if people use
their limited budget,
which we all have a
limited amount to spend,
if we spend more of it on
experiences and not stuff,
then people seem to be happier
from those experiences.
If we spend more money on
others rather than just buying
stuff for ourselves, we
seem to be happier as well.
So even though we can't wave a
magic wand and become richer,
maybe we can allocate
our spending differently
to try and improve
our happiness as well.
Another one is
fulfilling employment,
that if people feel in
control of their lives,
if they feel that they are
doing something they're good at,
that's another super strong
predictor of who is happy
and who's not.
Now, I think I know what
you're all thinking now.
I think what you're thinking
is, this is just too easy.
Like, all you're telling me
is, I need to get really rich.
I need to have amazing
relationships both romantically
and otherwise.
I need to find a job that
I'm, like, kickass at
and that I find really-- feel
in control and fulfilling.
Like, I'm just going to go home
tonight and be much happier.
But the thing is that actually
it's a bit more complicated
than that.
And the reason it's
more complicated
is because of this thing
called hedonic adaption.
Now, basically,
hedonic adaption,
it's not a good or a bad thing.
But it changes what it means
to try and pursue happiness.
If we're trying
to become happier,
then hedonic adaption
can be your enemy.
So let me explain.
Basically, everything
that we do,
everything that changes in
our lives, we just adapt to.
That's what the
human condition is.
We're supposed to
be good at adapting
to changing environments.
And that's the same
with happiness.
So even though
things that we think
might really impact our
happiness, we just adjust.
So within a few years, no matter
kind of what happens to us,
we seem to go back
to a set point.
So if you think about marriage,
you think that maybe--
I showed you that
relationships matter.
Maybe if we get married, we're
going to be much happier--
but, no.
We're happier a bit beforehand.
And we're really
happy on the day.
That's awesome.
And then [BLOWS RASPBERRY]
back to normal.
No, marriage, not
really helping.
Birth of a child?
Again, pretty
awesome just before.
Pretty crappy just afterwards.
But again, we just adjust
back to the set point.
Even when really
terrible things happen,
even when really awful things,
like the death of a spouse,
we do adjust back
within a few years.
You can even see there's
someone who's a bit happier
at the end there, but
that depends on gender,
and it depends on
a few other things.
But basically, we just
adapt to what happens to us.
Now this has really
important implications
for us pursuing happiness.
Because if we try to
pursue happiness but then
we know that we
adapt every time,
then we need to think about how
big the changes are that are
happening in our lives.
If we win the lottery tomorrow,
but then we adapt to that,
and in a couple of
years' time we're
back to normal
levels of happiness,
then we can't really
win the lottery twice.
So really, it's about steady
changes, steady gains.
People will be much
happier if they slowly
increase their income
over time than if they
had some massive windfall.
And similarly with
other areas of life,
slow goal fulfilment that feels
like you're making progress
is going to make people
happier than big changes.